but we do have more riots so um don't
worry the riots don't end oh they don't
don't worry guys this is more riots more
riots
riots rock montreal covid 19
lockdown protests turn ugly okay i mean
i don't blame them considering how the
uh
the the country the the federal
government up in in canada has been
behaving uh
but it is i mean it is fairly impolite
to write so i'm a little surprised
they're very polite up there yeah i
think uh i disagree with the rights i i
think the lockdowns
at this point are are proving to be have
been mistakes
uh we should have done i think what they
call the surgical strike where it's like
protect the elderly
protect the vulnerable and then have
like limited restrictions yep
now you got the today show they were
they were on the segment that goes viral
where they're like
texas and florida see their covid cases
going down
below the national average whereas
stricter states like new york and
california see their
cases rising what could be causing this
it's like
i don't know but at a certain point
maybe should be like
we're seeing something here fauci gets
asked about it and he's like i don't
know
okay well i mean the government has had
such a
a bad reaction to or bad
uh policy whatever you want to call it
to covid
since the beginning i'm still of the
opinion that
they were they proved themselves to be
unreliable
and not worth trusting when they were
telling people not to wear masks and
then
did the complete reversal especially
seeing as it seems to me if i understand
correctly
the reason they were telling people not
to wear masks was because
they were concerned about whether or not
people in the
uh in the medical field would have
enough they're literally lying to the
american people
about things they believed would be
helpful because
essentially it was triage you know right
about he said this
yeah he said like we just want to make
sure the medical community got their
masks so i don't trust the government at
all
you know about you know i'm kind of look
i'm i'm middle of the road right
i i gotta say the things that i find
bothersome are
you got a lot of tribalistically
pro-vexed people taking their selfies
and like gloating and smiling you get
brian stellar and cnn saying
why won't fox news post selfies with
their vaccines and i'm like
dude you're making it worse if you talk
to your doctor if your doctor recommends
it go with what your doctor says i was
talking to somebody and they said their
doctor actually recommended against it
because you know
wife was pregnant and they were
concerned about allergies and things
like that and i'm like your doctor knows
better than anybody
but then there are people who are like
mad at me because i'm like talk to your
doctor and if it's right for you
only your doctor can tell you yeah and i
got tons of friends who are posting
vaccine selfies
i roll my eyes guys it's like just i get
it you got your vaccine congratulations
yeah it really is i mean look they're
saying kovid might replace the flu we
know it's more serious than the flu we
know it's
infectious but i get it it
like i'm not gonna go to the doctor and
then post selfies and like join this
tribal crowd i think everybody's just
trying to play tribal politics on this
one it's really simple
that kind of stuff talk to your doctor
it's just absolute cringe
yeah it's it it's fine if you want to
get
the vaccine i'm likely to get one in the
next
week or two if i can get one in new
hampshire i'll be getting one um
do you know which brand you're gonna get
not the one that comes with
free blood clots that was the
astrazeneca one dude i saw this
really amazing meme video it is really
funny it's this dude
and he's like he's it's it's him acting
all the scenes he's one of these
tick-tock meme videos
and he's like he's playing playing the
patient sitting there like you know have
like lazily and the doctor you know
gives him the the the vaccine he's like
there you all you're there you go you're
all set then he goes
i've done it i've collected all five
and then he's like what do you mean and
he goes i've gotten the
pfizer the modern the astrazeneca the
johnson and johnson and the so flea or
whatever
and then the doctor's like you need to
go to the emergency room when you go
and then he punches the doctor in the
face and he's like why be immune when
you can be invincible
and then a guy runs in he's a cop and
then he like uses telekinesis on him it
was a great music
i wish i remember the guy's name was
funny i just uh a long story short
because uh uh i'm just kind of like look
they have new flu shots every year and
again i know the flu is is
is not nearly like covets worse i think
that the mortality is like double or
triple
but like i don't go to walgreens and
like take pictures and like dance around
and like all the meme stuff with on the
hospital it's just
look man i've always been rather
anti-establishment
and i guess to a certain degree punk
rock
i just i cringe at this like we're all
holding hands under the rainbow and
there's a doctor and post these selfies
i mean look it's it's bad that people
have lost their lives
and and have lost their you know their
their uh their jobs and and their
businesses and stuff
um one of the more first world problems
is just the level of cringe has gone
through the roof because of covet
the amount of people that are you know
the the whole superheroes bowing to
doctors
picture that i mean it's just um
you know i'm i'm for if you if your
doctor says you should get the vaccine
i'm forgetting it i'm gonna get it
because
i will do almost anything to get back on
tour again because i miss touring so
much i love playing shows
that's it's not just my livelihood i i
love performing so if i got to get a
vaccine to get on the road again
okay fine but man if i see one more
person
wearing two masks in their their default
picture
on in their bathroom oh it's just like
come on
come on these are it's i get that just
that you want to do this but it's all
this
this tribal virtue signal stuff it's
just you're gonna vomit
the weird the weird thing to me is like
uh i understand if people
are concerned about the vaccine because
it's under emergency use use
authorization
so it's not gone through final approval
sure sure i'm just like
talk to your doctor but you know i think
most of the people that have come
through here in the past month
have gotten their vaccines yeah and
we've like talked about it and they're
like oh yeah you know like it's not a
big deal and i'm like
what's this it's i wouldn't call it
anti-vaxx i would call it there's like
people who don't trust
what's you know vaccine and it's kind of
weird to me because i'm like i don't
know dude talk to your doctor
i get it like you're allowed to you're
allowed to do what you want read what
you want
but i just feel like the way i've always
explained it is i went to my doctor a
year ago and he prescribes me some like
crazy
you know i don't know what it's called
and i'm like it's like this weird long
word and i'm like
sounds good to me and now people are
like all of a sudden i'm concerned about
this i'm like dude
i think i think the vaccine passport
stuff goes over the top very very very
very over the top
yeah like it's be it's be you know yeah
but i i think your medical history is
your medical issue you talk to your
doctor your doctor tells you what to do
talk to a bunch of doctors i don't
i don't i i think we i think we've
beaten the dead horse on this one but
let's let's do this
you mentioned you want to go back on
tour absolutely man
check this out cdc director says
michigan needs to shut down again
amid rising chronovirus cases and will
not be able to vaccinate its way out of
a fourth spike come on man
i feel like i got people saying like
tim's shilling for vaccines and i'm like
dude
i've gotten a ton of vaccines before i
don't get it man i want that like a
flint
when they come back out and they're like
oh even if you get the vaccine we're
still shutting the state down i'm like
what am i supposed to tell people
if i can't go outside why i don't need
the vaccine
if you're telling me i can't go out i
can't go to the store all right well
once we start reopening i'll call my
doctor and say what do you think
i got food allergies that was always
like the issue for me on this i'm like
i'm not gonna
and i'm 35 man i'm not in the affected
group
but if they were like we're gonna reopen
everything and you know it's easier if
you get your vaccine then i'll be like
all right cool you know we're getting
back to the movie theaters and all that
stuff
you're not gonna wear a mask but they're
telling me i gotta wear two masks and i
can't go outside but go get it anyway
i'm like i'm chill i'll wait
like i don't understand i'm not trying
to be a dick i'm not trying to be like
anti-vex in any way i'm just saying i
mean i got time you know what i mean
yeah
again it comes back to the the the
mistrust of or at least for me
it comes back to the mistrust of
government because they've had had such
a bad even if it's just messaging the
messaging has been
so just abhorrently terrible just
disgusting
and right you're gonna have people that
don't you know that don't trust what
they're saying and
i mean i'm not i don't feel like i
should be expected to
know what to do i yell at a stick for a
living
right like i sing in a band like i am
not i'm not the guy to ask or to to tell
you what
you should do when it comes to
vaccinations i don't know
i have to go by what i read and by what
i hear and if if you're only going by
what you read and what you hear
you're literally basing your opinion on
someone else's opinion
right you know it's your goat you're
saying this guy i trust and this is what
i've heard from this guy
and so when it gets to people on you
know on twitter being
you know rude and stuff like that or
having the you know acting like they're
so much better than other people because
they're like oh this is what i believe
and
you're so dumb for taking the vaccine
because all the stuff that goes in there
you're so dumb for not taking the
vaccine because
wha what do you know you work at
you work at the pretzel place in the
mall shut your face
you know like you know you know what i
love it's like your doctor could
literally prescribe you like frazzle
basil bam shove it up your ass that's
the thing yeah and people are like you
got to duck
yeah i'm like it's between you and your
doctor man i don't want to know about
that and then because their doctor
recommended it they're going to talk to
you
like you're a [ __ ] because you're not
taking the suppository
right you can also get a second opinion
that's a big part of the medical
industry in fact you're often
not on twitter you're entitled to one
then you get banned
if a doctor tells you something and you
question it that's your right and you
also have the right to then a second and
maybe
a third opinion and to look to other
doctors and you should be researching
if you're going to stick stuff in your
body what you're doing with it uh i'm
just mad at fouchy
because he has been the biggest
discouraging factor in all of this
it's just like come on dude like texas
and florida are doing all right
you know what i mean i just came from
texas and and there are still some of
the
some of the larger chain stores like
walmart you still have to wear a mask
and stuff but smaller places and
and uh you know smaller businesses you
you know people don't wear them and it's
not
you know you don't see a lot of people
freaking out and i think
there might be something to the idea
that you know texas is you know hitting
80s and 90s now so people are outside
and
and not cooped up and maybe that does
have something to do with it but again
that's not how what the hell do i know i
i sing in a band i can only go by what
i'm what i'm seeing you know yeah
florida taxes are warm
and so it could be california though
yeah well it could be
you're outside you're less likely to
transmit perhaps yeah but again
not a doctor like like i said man
doctors prescribe you some weird stuff
but you know we borrowed a lot of money
to be able to do that stuff go
go talk to them and get your insurance
company to give them some money so they
can pay back their loans
but what's worrying to me is that at a
certain point people are just not going
to care anymore
and there was this one thing i think was
on cnn where this woman was like now is
our chance to get the vaccine out
because if we don't terrifying
they're like people are going to go out
and do their own thing anyway enjoy
their freedoms the worst thing about
that is
is the just she misunderstands
what the role of government is
misunderstands
anything about human liberty it
misunderstands
why people are free thinks that that
your the government gets its power from
the existence of the government as
opposed to the consent of the governed i
mean
it is just listening to that that
person go on i i i was appalled it was
it was one of the most one of the most
offensive things that i've heard in ages
and i'm not easily offended
yeah it's like they're going to enjoy
their freedom anyway so now's our chance
like yeah come on dude thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you